if I were to ask you what is 5 minus 3
plus 2 what would you say that is pause
this video and try to figure that out
all right well if you wanted to tackle
this you would really just read it from
left to right or you would compute it
from left to right you'd first figure
out what 5 minus 3 is and 5 minus 3 is
equal to 2 and so you'd say okay that's
going to be 2 plus 2 which of course we
know is equal to 4 now what if I were to
involve a little bit of multiplication
or division if I were to go up to you
and I were to say what is 5 plus 3 times
2 pause this video and try to figure
that out well you might be tempted to do
it in a similar way you might be tempted
to say okay I'll just go from left to
right I'll first compute what 5 plus 3
is and that of course would be equal to
8 and then I would multiply 8 times 2 to
get 16 but it turns out that this would
not be the right way to approach this
because for very good reasons that will
study in perhaps future videos we don't
always go left to right especially when
we're dealing with different types of
operations and the standard way that
this is approached is that
multiplication and division will be done
before addition and subtraction so the
way that you would actually compute this
is that you would compute the 3 times 2
first so you would say that this is the
same thing as 5 plus 6 5 plus 6 which is
going to be equal to 11 not 16 so this
is going to be equal to 11 so with that
out of the way let's do a few more
examples let's say someone were to
approach you and say what is 9 minus 6
divided by 3 pause this video and see if
you can figure that
well as I just said we would do
multiplication or division before we do
subtraction so we'll actually do the six
divided by three first and six divided
by three is two so this simplifies to 9
minus 2 which is equal to 7 and I really
want to emphasize it's important that
you get this idea that multiplication
and division should be done before the
addition or subtraction unless you're
given some other types of directions
because if you just went left to right
here you were to said 9 minus 6 is 3 and
then you would have divided that by 3
which you've got which would have given
you 1 which is clearly a different
number than 7 let's do one more example
just just for kicks let's say that
someone were to ask you what is 2 times
3 minus 1 pause the video and try to
figure that one out well in this one
doing our multiplication first is also
the same as going left to right first so
if we do 2 times 3 first
2 times 3 is 6 so that's 6 and then we
would want to calculate 6 minus 1 which
is of course equal to 5 so big picture
if you just have a bunch of things that
are being added subtracted multiplying
and divided and there's no parentheses
in it you would always prioritize the
multiplication or the division over the
addition or the subtraction